[Music]
on this tuesday night terrorism charges
laid in a murder case
did a deadly attack on this young woman
amount to terrorism
she was an amazing mother what's behind
the first of its kind charge in canada
no longer locked up more businesses
reopen their doors
with new rules we're also going to be
quarantining the items once someone's
tried them
the safety of canada's snowbirds
questions about the aging jets
and potential transportation
transformation
it's been really positive to have the
change in air quality
the drive to get commuters on a more
eco-friendly path
permanently
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
police in toronto are treating the
vicious murder of a woman in february
as an act of terrorism after discovering
evidence it may have been motivated by
violent misogyny
the charges are a first for canada the
suspect who is a minor
is alleged to have entered a massage
parlor in downtown toronto brandishing a
machete
he was first charged with murder and
attempted murder that's now been
upgraded to a terrorism
charge police found evidence he was
linked to the so-called incel
movement men who believe the world is
stacked against
unattractive heterosexual men it is a
growing threat
it festers online as jeff semple
explains tonight
this pandemic could be making it worse
jeff
donna the 17 year old allegedly stormed
into this massage parlor and went on a
stabbing spree
his victims chosen because of their
gender now for the first time
anywhere in the world police are calling
this type of attack
terrorism the attack on the massage
parlor left one woman injured
and another dead ashley noel arzaga
a 24 year old mother one of the
survivors spoke to global news by phone
she was an amazing and amazing mother
she was the brightest character ever
police say their alleged attacker was
inspired by incel
short for involuntary celibates the
misogynist movement promotes violence
against
women but never before has an incel
linked attacker
been charged with terrorism this charge
is really huge news for canada and
internationally
terrorism charges in canada have
traditionally been reserved for islamist
extremists
inspired by groups such as al qaeda and
the so-called islamic state
what's required under the canadian
criminal code is that the intent is to
intimidate
the public so to create fear in the
public and that's
precisely what um in cells call for
when they're perpetrating violence since
2014
incel inspired attacks in canada and the
united states have killed around 50
people
including 10 victims of toronto's van
attack a couple of years ago
that attacker explicitly told police
he'd been radicalized online
by incels i felt it was time to take
action and not just
he was charged with 10 counts of first
degree murder
but not terrorism traditionally we have
treated
the far right either as a regular crime
problem so which is to say if it's an
assault it's charged an assault or if
it's a murder or attempted murder it's
charged as such
or as hate speech so why the sudden
change in tactic
security experts say islamist extremism
remains the number one terrorist threat
in canada
but incel and other far-right groups are
fast
catching up it really signals that the
canadian government
is taking you know right-wing extremism
but particularly
misogynistic violence very very
seriously and
elevating it to the level of terrorism
this also means that now all of the
tools and techniques that intelligence
and security service
says use to combat terrorism can now be
deployed against
this threat another reason why
prosecutors have proved reluctant to
charge with terrorism
is because it's unlikely to make much of
a difference when it comes to sentencing
the 17 year old in this case is already
charged with first degree murder
and as a young offender he faces a
maximum sentence of six years
in prison donna
jeff semple in toronto thank you you can
read more about incel
extremism and why it is on the rise
that's on our website global news dot ca
slash
global national now to the pandemic and
where we're at in terms of numbers
as ontario and other provinces begin to
open up there are now more than 79 000
confirmed cases across the country
nearly 6 000 people have died from covet
19.
50 percent of all the confirmed cases
have now fully recovered
quebec continues to be the worst
affected 570 new cases were confirmed in
the last 24 hours
and 51 more people are known to have
died ontario has surpassed
23 000 confirmed cases and today
recorded 427 new ones
and 15 more people died there most of
the deaths from covet 19 in canada have
been residents in long-term care homes
the system is broken now ontario is
launching an independent commission
to examine long-term care nearly
fourteen hundred residents in ontario
and five staff members have died
the number of care homes in ontario with
active outbreaks has grown in recent
weeks despite
the restrictions and precautions being
taken
ontarians deserve answers to their
questions
this is a global pandemic that has
inflicted
tremendous tragedy on our long-term care
homes
many of them and we need to get to the
bottom of that
most of the people who have died in
quebec from copenhagen are also
residents in long-term care today
quebec's premier francois lego said he
too is open to an inquiry ontario is
beginning the transition to reopening
the economy
this is the first day in about 10 weeks
that some businesses were able to
operate again
schools though will remain shut for the
rest of the school year
an emergency order remains in place
keeping bars and restaurants closed
except for takeout and delivery
and limited gatherings to no more than
five people
as abigail beeman reports what happens
next depends on
what happens now
switching out change room curtains for
doors just one of the changes at
ottawa's flock
boutique reopening wednesday doors and
physical distancing are provincial rules
others the co-owners had to figure out
themselves we're also going to be
quarantining the items once someone's
tried them
we'll be putting them aside for at least
24 hours and then steaming them as well
now it's it's survival we're in survival
mode the head of the local business
improvement association says only about
10 or 15 percent of businesses in the
area reopened
more expected in the next two weeks a
challenge
it's hard to keep track of what's
allowed to open and how
with things constantly changing really
the next few weeks as things open up
will tell us as well
how much damage there has been but i can
tell you there have been closures and
there will be more
and the job right now is to make sure we
support those businesses that are there
in addition to retail stores with
separate street entrances
ontario's phase one means pet groomers
are allowed to open tuesday
she's always very concerned about our
animals so she didn't even take his
leash
some spectator free sports involving
minimal contact can start again
too tennis track and field and horse
racing
in-person counseling is back on and
construction limits lifted
many were holding their breath to see if
kids would go back to school this year
the national a propensity to hug and
play
and maybe it's already at the end of the
school year let's just curtail it a
little bit more
and see what happens in the fall turned
out the premier agrees
i'm just not going to risk it
this wasn't an easy decision to make but
it was the right decision
but with more ontario parents heading
back to work with no
school child care becomes a problem the
premier says child care centers will
reopen as part of phase two
but there's no set date for that to
happen just yet
abigail beeman global news ottawa
saskatchewan which recorded just seven
new cases today is entering phase two of
its reopening plan
hair salons are back in business with
hygiene and physical distancing measures
in place
retail stores and malls are allowed to
open but some stores will be appointment
only
to limit the numbers bc also began phase
two of its reopening plan
today the retail sector restaurants pubs
and cafes
along with child care centers are
allowed to reopen
there are strict guidelines though and
limits on the number of customers
health services have restarted too
including elective surgeries
physiotherapy and some
dental procedures the canada-us border
is staying closed to non-essential
travel until at least
june 21st it's been closed since march
21st and
prime minister justin trudeau says it
could be months before the border opens
to more than just trade and essential
workers
the u.s has the most cases and the most
deaths from covid19
in the world now that the american
president has said he's taking a drug
that's not approved for use against
covid19
there is a lot of confusion donald trump
has promoted hydroxychloroquine as a
miracle cure but there's
no conclusive scientific evidence to
back that up
in fact there are warnings taking it to
try to prevent covid19 could lead
to serious side effects trump has always
been a leader who thinks he knows best
but
this time it's not just his own health
he's risking it's public health
jackson proskow reports perhaps it's not
surprising that a president who so often
clashes with experts would make himself
a medical test subject
this is an individual decision to make
but it's had a great reputation
and if it was somebody else other than
me people would say gee isn't that smart
in defiance of warnings from his own
government regulators
trump claims he has started taking
hydroxychloroquine
the anti-malarial drug has not been
proven to prevent people from
contracting covid19
trump says he asked his doctors for it
anyway after potential exposure to the
virus through his personal valet
i think it gives you an additional level
of safety but you can as many doctors
are in favor of it
many front line workers won't go there
unless they have the hydroxy
the opposite seems to be true several
studies have shown the drug is at best
ineffective
in patients who actually have the virus
there are warnings of dangerous side
effects including heart problems
there are potential side effects that
include psychosis hallucinations
liver damage and these really dangerous
cardiac arrhythmias that could be fatal
given trump's age the fact that he's
overweight and has a history of cardiac
disease
doctors question whether he should be
taking the medication at all
let alone promoting it to the general
public and they may be
hearing what the president is saying and
thinking oh i should be taking this
medication too
the prime minister did not share trump's
enthusiasm
health canada has warned against the
unsupervised use of the drug
i will continue to follow advice of
medical professionals
and implore every canadian to follow the
best advice of our medical health
experts
back in washington trump again finds
himself in a fight against science
going so far as to suggest studies that
showed the drug could be dangerous
were politically motivated it was a
trump enemy
statement and while all that is going on
the president
is pushing ahead with his campaign
against the world health organization
in a tersely worded letter to the who
trump says that if the organization does
not make substantial changes in the next
30 days
the u.s will suspend funding permanently
donna
jackson proskow in washington thanks
fresh questions about
old jets coming up why a former
commander of the snowbirds is confident
about the aircraft's safety
the recovery mission of a canadian
forces helicopter which went down off
the coast of greece is ramping up
the cyclone helicopter crashed in the
ocean during a nato training
exercise killing all six on board u.s
navy personnel and a u.s navy
submersible are being brought to the
site
to find and then recover the wreck which
lies about three thousand meters
under the mediterranean sea the focus is
to find and repatriate the four
remaining bodies believed to be
inside the chopper canadian armed forces
aircraft have begun transporting u.s
experts from the continental united
states along with deep submersible
technologies
to greece to prepare for the search and
hopefully the recovery
of as many of our fallen and as much as
of the machine as possible
it has been a tough few weeks for the
canadian armed forces
today prime minister justin trudeau paid
tribute to the troops who have died
including captain jen casey she was
killed when the snowbirds jet she was in
crashed on sunday
the prime minister called her an
outstanding service woman remembered not
just for her professionalism but her
sense of humor
and kindness the pilot captain richard
mcdougall
survived the crash of the tudor jet
which dates back to the 1960s is now
under investigation
robin gill is in kamloops bc where it
went down
robin donna this is the ninth deadly
incident involving the snowbird since
1972
and every time there's a crash the role
of the snowbirds and whether there
should be new planes
become a debate
a melancholy tribute to a captain whose
young life was cut
short another token of respect at the
growing memorial
to jennifer casey behind the fence at
the kamloops airport
the planes she loved so much are parked
on the tarmac
their mission paused but robert mitchell
a pilot
and former commander of the team has no
trepidations about getting into the
cockpit of those planes
i can say unequivocally i would get in
that jet tomorrow
i really love that airplane
sunday's disaster in kamloops involving
a snowbird jet has made this
neighborhood
the focus of a military investigation
the pieces are scattered in yards where
the plane
shattered according to federal
government reports the jets were
supposed to be retired in 2010
but the date was extended to 2030
despite
significant concerns the prime minister
won't say
if the planes will be grounded for good
there is going to be a proper
investigation and we're going to allow
them
to do their work before we make
assumptions about what
might be the outcome of that
investigation the canadian-built tudor
jets have been operating
since the 1960s the snowbirds program
has been used to recruit young people to
the military
like captain richard mcdougall the
34-year-old new brunswick native was
recently interviewed about being the
team's newest member
it's a great little jet to fly i haven't
had too many flights on it yet
but i should be done my conversion
shortly mcdougall has been trained on
other planes and
just became the snowbirds coordinator he
was at the controls of the plane when it
spiraled to
the ground he survived with serious but
non-life-threatening injuries
mitchell too was a young pilot when he
joined the snowbirds in 1999.
it's something i identified as a young
boy as
a prototypically canadian
an identity and now a grief shared by so
many canadians
the planes will likely be on pause for
many months because this investigation
is only just beginning
and could take up to a year donna
robin gill and kamloops bc thank you
a police document unsealed by a judge in
nova scotia
is giving some insight tonight into that
mass shooting in nova scotia
the 40-page redacted document reveals
police believe the gunman
had gathered firearms ammunition
explosives and chemicals
including 800 dollars worth of gasoline
and witnesses who spoke to the police
say the killer was
paranoid about the covet 19 pandemic the
allegations have not been proven in
court
in april 22 people were murdered in a
13-hour rampage across
rural nova scotia the killer was dressed
in an authentic rcmp uniform
and was driving a replica rcmp cruiser
ahead the last tasmanian tiger the newly
released footage of a long
extinct species
more than two million people are being
urged to move inland as supercyclone
ampham heads towards india and
bangladesh it's expected to make
landfall tomorrow
with wind guts of up to 160 kilometers
an hour and heavy rain
pandemic quarantine centers have been
converted into emergency shelters
because the storm is now
a more immediate danger than kovid 19.
a museum in australia has released rare
video of a now
extinct predator this is the last known
footage of a
thylacine known as a tasmanian tiger it
was taken in 1935 his name was benjamin
he lived at a zoo in tasmania
he died a few months after this he
wasn't a tiger at all but a marsupial
they typically had stripes a pouch and a
dog-like head with powerful jaws
they were hunted to extinction
bicycle boom next how covid19 has led
to greener commutes
if we are to harvest british fruit and
vegetables this year
we need an army of people to help
food that's the prince of wales calling
on people to pick for britain
food he says does not happen by magic he
wants students and people laid off
because of covid19 to work with farmers
this summer
without enough help fruits and
vegetables could be left to rot
the campaign is modeled after the second
world war land army
prince charles says he knows it's hard
on glamorous work but it's a vital
contribution to the country
uk farmers rely heavily on migrant
workers as we do here in canada
kovid 19 travel restrictions mean
producers are facing
a shortage of workers
the travel bans and lockdowns to stop
the spread of covid19 have significantly
reduced greenhouse gas emissions
new data published in the journal nature
climate change
shows a 17 drop in daily co2 emissions
in early april compared to the same time
last year
they say this shows just how difficult
it is to lower emissions without
drastic changes to how we live our lives
here in canada there was a 20
decrease in april in the uk co2
emissions dipped
as much as 31 percent
our cities have become cleaner and
quieter in this pandemic but as
economies begin to reopen we'll start
going back to our old ways so
work is now underway to make long-term
changes to the way we commute
healthier and greener options that still
maintain physical distance
redmond shannon reports from london
during lockdown ridership on london's
transit network
dropped more than 80 percent it's proved
to be a
boom for the bicycle with some stores
even selling out
a lot of people are straining with money
so a lot of the times they're
coming looking for like a nice cheap bag
for about 250 quid
upwards just so they can get around
canola wants to travel on the buses at
the moment
half a million people normally travel
into london's historic financial
district
every day and soon manny will start
returning to work on these old
narrow streets where physical distancing
will be a
serious challenge the local borough
council has acted quickly
aiming to keep cyclists and walkers safe
while also discouraging driving in order
to do that to facilitate the space we
need to
redesignate parts of the carriageway to
active
transport i.e cycling and pedestrians
the roadways will become
shared spaces or restricted to motor
vehicles
during office hours the opportunity in
the pandemic as well as the duty
allows us to push forward some of those
plans
faster than we would otherwise have
anticipated other parts of london are
already widening sidewalks cities across
europe
are doing the same advocates for greener
travel say
this could be an unexpected upside of
the pandemic
it's been really positive to have the
change in air quality
to see more families getting out we'd
love to see some of these temporary
measures made permanent we hope
that you know people do walk more the
city of london says
many measures could become permanent but
for now the priority will be giving
commuters
the space they need redmond shannon
global news
london and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
it's been 40 years since the marathon of
hope when terry fox made that remarkable
attempt to run across canada
the fundraising for cancer research has
never stopped
now adidas is relaunching the blue orion
sneaker that's the one fox wore on his
epic journey
one hundred percent of the net proceeds
will go to the terry fox foundation
before he started the run fox wrote to
adidas asking for help and it sent him
26 pairs of orion's shoes you can share
what fox in his marathon means to you
using the hashtag thanks terry
and thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]